today we're talking about the new sci-fi
heist shooter that was announced as well
as all the new info on xenoblade
chronicles 3 and more
creative assembly creators of total war
and alien isolation have teamed up with
sega for a newly announced game called
hyenas hyenas is a team-based shooter
tasking players with robbing high-tech
vaults on massive space freighters and
then escaping the scene of the crime
each match has 15 players split into
three teams of five but players will
also have to deal with npc enemies and
security systems the game seems to take
a bit of inspiration from apex legends
and hunt's showdown but the colorfulness
also gives me valoran and overwatch
vibes an interesting feature of the
gameplay is that some areas are in zero
gravity while others have a zero gravity
switch and players can toggle it on and
off to get the upper hand on enemies or
get themselves into a whole lot of
trouble the goal is to pick up as much
loot as possible but rather than money
or precious metals the valuables are pop
culture artifacts a sonic figurine a
rubik's cube and various new york city
related memorabilia all make an
appearance in hyena's debut trailer not
a lot is known about the playable
characters at this time but abilities
shown include a goop deploying weapon
similar to the one in 2017's prey
deployable turrets a flashbang a jet
pack and more no release date was
announced for hyenas but if you have a
pc and live in north america or europe
you can sign up for the upcoming alpha
on the game's official website now let's
switch gears to a game that has a ton of
new info xenoblade chronicles 3. today's
nintendo direct laid out the game's
story and battle system focusing on the
party's six classes and their abilities
these classes include swordfighter
zephyr medic gunner tactician heavy
guard and ogre nintendo also revealed
the xenoblade chronicles 3 expansion
pass adding over a year's worth of
additional content for 30 bucks the pass
will include special color variants on
the game's launch day two packs
including new heroes quests and
challenges and a story expansion set to
be released by the end of 2023 amiibo
support was also confirmed for xc3
allowing players to scan every amiibo
for extra items hit the comments and let
me know your hype levels for xenoblade 3
while i tell you all about how i'm
excited for the new stuff coming to
forza horizon 5. the game's latest
update adds story mode co-op a new event
and new hot wheels cars and cosmetics
ahead of the july expansion release the
patch also fixes a number of
high-profile bugs adds convertible
functionality to some of the cars plus
add support for a handful of new
languages in both subtitles and
voiceovers with the amount of content
that's being added and tweaked users
have reported that the patch is a hefty
one with a file size of around 16 gigs
on xbox series x and 12 gigs on the xbox
one for the full list of patch notes
i'll have a link in the description and
if you made it this far into the video
go ahead and hit the comment section and
let me know what you preferred growing
up or what you prefer now matchbox or
hot wheels i recently found out that
they're both made by mattel so like
they're almost the same thing why why
did i hate matchbox growing up
you